bonjour à tous alors
midi
merci pour l'introduction j'ai plus rien
t'es juste j'ai été étonné de
l'invitation au départ parce que je suis
ordinaire ordinaire 46 ans marié trois
enfants un toit sur la tête nos voitures
enfin 46 ans est vrai qu'à mon âge
normalement le dit pas trop moi j'assume
40 ans j'ai dit j'assume
bon bah j'assume j'aime bien marié 20
ans de mariage cette année on a fait la
fête
il est parti en voyage très bien c'est
vrai c'est pas dans les stats à non plus
20 ans mais c'est bien puis je resigne
froch lui aussi d'ailleurs tabac trois
enfants maintenant ils sont grands ça
non plus pas dans la moyenne un peu
moins de deux je crois en france il faut
vous mettre au boulot parce que les
retraites falloir y aller 1 3 enfant
j'en aurais même un quatrième bon le
papa il n'a pas voulu il avait déjà
trois enfants mes trois fils alors
quatre filles à la maison il a dit stop
on arrête
bon donc ça c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément super ordinaire finalement
disons que c'est pas très banal un toit
à toit alors j'ai pas du tout la maison
avec le petit jardin le chien pas du
tout j'ai un petit appart bien pratique
qui était du provisoire qu'a duré sa ne
voit bien donc voilà c'est vrai que
c'est pas conventionnel
une voiture une voiture oui j'ai même
trois comme dit ma fille avec les trois
on achète n'est pas une neuve mais sa
mort ça répond aux besoins ça me va bien
alors c'est pas super dans l'image non
plus c'est vrai alors pas conventionnel
pas banal pas ordinaire pas dans l'image
va donc c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément ordinaire ce de ville a
finalement
et pourtant rien d'exceptionnel aussi
j'ai pas de compte facebook
j'ai pas accroché
j'aime bien j'aime bien la tablette
enfin leur dit ça j'aime bien il ya
vingt ans et j'ai commencé à travailler
mais que première transmission internet
ça vous parle pas vous mais nous c'était
énorme à l'époque on en attend un peu
plus ce matin d'ailleurs autant rien
mais bon donc oui ça c'est un peu
particulier c'est vrai mais bon
et puis quand on y regarde si le cursus
pour arriver aujourd'hui eh ben ils
n'étaient pas forcément très linéaire et
ordinaire c'est vrai départ moi je
voulais faire de l'agriculture
ajoutez y percer dans le métier
j'adorais moins directe de fruits
c'était mon truc
jack basket dans les champs à faire là
marchante j'adorerais ça m'est vraiment
j'adorais donc j'ai fait on va les faire
plaisir aux parents donc on a d'abord
passé un bac bac agricole des primes
mais il existe plus heureusement parce
que le coup vous avez fait une déprime
oui j'ai des prix mais agronomie
biologie quand même pas loin à la
motte-servolex c'était bien c'était une
très bonne expérience parce que j'ai
bien aimé les études et puis comme ça
marchait pas mal je continuais bts
technico-commercial en fruits et légumes
ça m'allait bien plus j'étais dans mon
domaine tout allait bien
puis j'ai rencontré mon copain
l'histoire ordinaire comme dirait cabrel
je sais pas si une référence pour vous
une veille de jour férié soirées
étudiantes
désolé mais bon et puis mon copain et
par lui il est le bts ils étaient là par
hasard
et puis l'a pas aimé est devenu
cuisinier et mois après le stage
formation bts tout ça ça valait bien ça
marchait bien j'étais dans mes fruits
tout allait bien et je me suis fait
embaucher par mon maître de stage c'est
vachement important les stages sait plus
qui en parlait l'expérience de stage
c'est super important
ça nous permet de voir autre chose et
puis après c'est des bons tremplins
alors embaucher donc je vendais mes
fruits savent que mes fruits ben je
côtoyais encore le producteur mais je
m'en des plus vraiment aux clients je
vendais aux grandes surfaces aux
centrales d'achat
et puis après l'hiver j'ai passé chez un
semencier de pommes de terre et je
vendais sur le marché anglais super à
l'époque j'étais un peu loin quand même
deux mots ma première idée de faire de
la vente directe
et puis entre temps donc mon mon copain
a été donnée cuisine et donc on se
croisaient sur la route
et puis à 25 ans vous
vous avez quand même un pas envie de
sortir et tous et non en restauration
l'histoire les week-ends on oublie donc
c'était compliqué et puis la pression
dans le boulot elle devenait de plus en
plus importante
le marché prenait de l'ampleur on
partait parti en angleterre faire des
salons achats super mais j'étais loin
quand même de mon rêve du départ et puis
comme le disait je crois annette je me
trompe pas la tête a commencé à gratter
et moi je pleure moi je pleure beaucoup
mais quand vous arrivez au boulot devant
votre patron puis vous commencez à être
même fontaine ça ne fait pas et puis bah
ça a commencé à pas le faire du tout
et du coup j'ai arrêté j'ai écouté les
petites voix et puis finalement je me
suis dit pourquoi pas la restauration on
va se mettre en parallèle avec s'allier
avec ce qu'on a envie avec en
l'occurrence je n'ai envie d'être avec
mon copain pourquoi pas et du coup j'ai
tout posé et je retourne à l'école en c1
pbp restaurant alors c'est pareil pour
l'image ça le fait pas en bts commercial
international entre guillemets et vous
retournez à l'école pour passer ainsi ap
beyrouth et restaurants là vous voyez
des copains parce que ce qu'on va
continuer sur la même voie commerce que
vous leur dites ça ils sont moins
copains près certain mais je regrette
pas parce que ce métier j'ai réappris à
la base c'est ça n'a pas été simple ans
j'ai jamais autant travaillé de toute ma
vie facile la deuxième fois je vous
dirai quand quand il faut passer ainsi
ab bep en restaurant vous n'y connaissez
rien en va en fromage en hébergement
rien
moi j'étais jobs basket paysanne j'avais
laissé jack basque
parce que j'étais passé quand même jean
chemise en commercial quand même et là
vous vous retrouvez dans un espèce de
tailleurs cintrés macha servir des gens
bon bah on y va et puis finalement pas
jouer à la marchande avec les clients
après je vais faire en alternance
c'était sympa
puis j'aimais et je suis tombé dans ce
métier vraiment et puis ça m'a plu donc
ça c'est en 90 s est derrière et bien
pendant deux ans à travailler et avec
mon copain depuis
en plus on l'a travaillé dans les mêmes
resto parce qu'on est même bien
travaillé ensemble
on s'entendait bien on s'entendait bien
dans la bien certains des meilleurs
boulots vous pouvez avoir les mêmes
jours de congé ça y est on vivait notre
vie sympa de jeunes et où donc super et
comme on avait déjà travaillé un peu et
puis une certaine maturité j'allais dire
par rapport à nos expériences passées à
nos écoles et maintenant les restes ont
été trouvés très vite à être responsable
de restaurant responsable de salle et
c'est donc des postes super intéressant
très concentré on a travaillé comme des
dingues mais on aimait ça ce qui fait
que deux ans après on est rentré chez
maître kanter alors ça existe plus bien
maintenant mois en mois cd grosse
brasserie ça bouge alors vous comptez
pas vos heures à l'époque on comptait
passer de l'or et mais ça bougeait bien
on a eu un super patron et en 98 mon
copain il me demande en mariage alors
tous les gens qui me connaissent sont
atterrés que ce soit lui qui soit jetée
à l'eau ce qui n'est pas forcément
france heures on parlait des couleurs
thaler c'était sympa d'habitude c'est
plus moi le rouge
et si on était un mâle ans tous les deux
et toute notre famille et déparle à lyon
pour chara jambes et enfin peu par là et
en ses montées notre mariage à tous les
deux et ça ça a été un déclic
non seulement c'est bien entendu c'est
pareil on a bien bossé et alors surtout
les parents on leur a demandé de nous
aider parce qu'on n'avait pas ou peu de
sous mais alors où ils ont fait le
chèque c'est tout nous on s'est occupé
du reste on est même allés choisir la
robe de mariée ensemble c'est génial at
oui je conseille c'est pas bien
conventionnel mais c'est génial c'est
très marrant on a monté ce projet
ensemble et je crois que ça a été la
petite ce qui a germé
c'est que ça nous plaisait devenaient
des projets ensemble et en 99 ans est
retrouvé ans et marié on a démissionné
notre boulot on avait les bonnes places
tous les deux mais on a démissionné et
on s'est mis dans l'idée de chercher un
restaurant pour s'installer pour
vraiment vivre une aventure à tous les
deux et on a trouvé pas loin novalaise
petit village de campagne donc on
voulait laisser valence la ville on
voulait revenir à la campagne ça c'était
un fait et puis on voulait avoir un
petit peu de verdure dans notre vif un
petit jardin par exemple parce qu'alors
la ville
ça nous plaisait plus l'espagne à
l'horaire voilà moi je veux pas le
dessin chaque fois c'était pareil et du
coup anciens on a trouvé un petit resto
de campagne une petite crêperie d'été et
le challenge était de l'ouvrir à l'année
en y mettant de la restauration
et puis on est arrivé finalement il n'y
a pas beaucoup qui croyait mais on y est
arrivé parce que c'était notre projet un
nom qu'on s'est toujours remis en
question pour s'adapter qu'on a fait
avec le coeur et que on était en phase
aligné alors là j'avais quitté les
costumes d'école
je servais plus en étant nature et mais
assez bien et on vivait bien tout ça on
avait notre défi notre famille notre
boulot en est arrivés on s'était dit
disant ce que la grande question c'est
de savoir si on allait supporter 24 sur
24 tous les deux vous sans se taper
dessus
en travaillant c'était pas sûr et
c'était le voilà le plus gros défi
jaillir et ça nous a permis de vivre nos
nos passions qu'ils étaient devenus les
voyages finalement avec le premier
voyage qu'on a fait c'était notre lune
de notre voyage 9 mai à notre voyage de
noces vu qu'on avait tout ce qu'il
fallait on avait fait liste pour notre
mariage donc on est parti
thaïlande bas livre un super voyage sac
à dos et toute notre vie professionnelle
avec donc ce petit resto on a pu
travailler beaucoup et puis fermer le
restaurant et partir en voyage pendant
10 ans on a fait ça on a fait des supers
boyer ajourné partir nouvelle zélande
m'appartient vraiment quatre coins du
monde avec nos enfants parce qu'entre
temps
eh ben on a une note 3 louloute est
derrière au moutain 12 ans commence à
pleurer
on arrête on a vendu et on se remit
ensuite donc bien vendu super expérience
vraiment on s'est replongés vraiment du
travail
alors mon mari l'a trouvé très vite à un
poste de chef cuisinier le monde il
travaille il avait un peu changé parce
qu'on était il y avait eu les 35 heures
jusqu'au deçà bon quand on est un petit
peu décalé quand même
et là ça a été un peu compliqué donc
bonne remise en question et c'est là où
la l'université savoie mont blanc m'a
aidé en passant la licence en validation
des acquis ça m'a vraiment permis de
tourner la page de ce qui avait été fait
parce que c'est notre construction quand
même professionnel pendant 15 ans qui
avait été fait mais de faire le point et
de leur donner confiance ici sur ce que
je pouvais faire donc c'est important à
un moment donné de bien écouter et de
bien valoriser qui on est dans la valeur
ajoutée de leur valentin c'est important
de redonner de la valeur ajoutée à ce
que vous êtes de prendre le temps de
faire le point de remettre en question
pour pouvoir avoir confiance en vous
c'est important
suite à la vae j'ai pu donc avoir la
licence travailler dans un hôtel 4
étoiles
alors là on était loin de jeans baskets
paysans du départ on était plus en
tailleur je pensais pas être capable de
faire ça j'ai beaucoup aimé ça m'a
beaucoup appris j'ai pu m'occuper de mes
enfants parce que j'avais les soirées
c'était impeccable au bout de deux ans
et demi j'avais fait le tour de la
question
je trouve à notre boulot et c'est pareil
jamais j'aurais imaginé pouvoir postuler
en tant qu'adjointe de direction dans un
restaurant dans une jeep dans une chaîne
en l'occurrence alors que paradoxalement
pendant quinze ans on avait été à notre
compte et c'est là où c'est important de
toujours se reconnecter avec le monde du
travail et d'avoir confiance en vous et
en vos valeurs et toujours les
confronter avec j'allais dire une
certaine référence donc aujourd'hui la
seule chose j'allais dire que j'ai envie
de pour finaliser l'histoire des
vêtements je vous ai fait un petit peu
ce parallèle pour vous dire c'est
important pour vous vous allez voir en
face des fois vous allez être obligé
entre guillemets obligé de vous
confronter à certains monde de rentrer
dans certain moule alors c'est encore un
petit peu être compliqué ou comment
expliquer jade avec les couleurs de
parler le même langage de la personne en
face dont il ya un côté qui est
important sur votre apparence qu'il faut
pas négliger même si vous pouvez être
fiers de ce que vous êtes vous pouvez
assumer ce que vous êtes vaut pas
négliger c'est important je pense est
l'autre point sur lequel je vous ai
parlé tout le temps c'était des voyages
de vivre ne pas oublier s'allier à côté
vraiment profitez-en
vous voyez du monde et surtout alors
vive et même si ça ne paraît pas
conventionnel même si ça fait peur au
gens parce que partir en sac à dos en
sri lanka avec trois enfants de 7 à 9
ans je peux vous dire que les parents
nos parents ils ont un petit peu la
trouille quand même et il n'était pas
très rassuré pinon par trois semaines et
on donne pas une nouvelle pour nos trois
semaines ils ont pas bien digéré mais
c'est pas grave ici sont fait donc vivez
vos rêves
croyez en vous et surtout n'oubliez pas
et aujourd'hui vous en avez eu les
témoignages aussi bien avec fabio des
parcs avec annette
n'oubliez pas les petites voix qui sont
en vous parce que c'est elle
si on est en phase tout l'univers
conspirent pour votre réussite
merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]